hi welcome to cloud air live webinars
from Google cloud we host these live
webinar session every Tuesdays today we
are going to talk about GD P R and G
sweet
my name is Adina Baucus and I'm a
privacy program manager in Google cloud
I'm based in Sunnyvale California and I
work very closely with engineers on some
of our data protection programs you can
ask questions anytime on the platform we
have Google you are standing by to
answer them and also we will have a Q&A
at the end so let's get started so first
when I was asked to talk about the gdpr
I was thinking oh man I probably can
talk about the gdpr for days but I know
we have limited time today so I decided
to focus on certain aspects of the gdpr
which is how it relates to Google Cloud
and specifically how we in G suite can
support our customers and GDP our
compliance so first of all I just wanted
to give a general high-level overview of
the GDP our what is the GDP are the GDP
R stands for the general general the
general data protection regulation in
Europe and this is by far the most
significant data protection legislation
that came out from Europe in the last
many years and the last one of course
the European Data Protection Directive
20 years ago and 20 years ago it was a
very different era in terms of the
internet internet was not as commonly
used and especially there was not so
much personal data on it what is some
other big difference between the
European Data Protection Directive from
20 years ago and the general data
protection
regulation is that the directive is a
directive which means that it directed
member states to pass their own Paris
legislation the result was similar laws
but somewhat of a patchwork and that
made compliance very challenging from
customers and providers alike and the
gdpr intends to harmonize these laws and
it's also a regulation but which means
that it has the direct effect of the law
so it's legally binding and member
states don't have to pass by separate
legislation and of course it's it's very
it means to be much more convenient for
customers and providers alike the
probably the most important thing about
the GDP are that it enhances data
subject rights it's building on existing
beta protection principles such as data
minimization storage limitation purpose
purpose limitation what does it mean it
means that when a company collects data
for a specific purpose it should be
processed for only that purpose and only
for a time period necessary and of
course there are other theater
production principles such as lawfulness
fairness transparency theater accuracy
integrity and so forth we find all of
these data protection principles in the
gdpr
and the data subject rights build on
these principles for example data
integrity accuracy means that data
subject rights have a right to request
to request to rectify from companies to
store the data that - from the companies
about the data that they store about
them the right to rectification right to
access the right to restrict for data
possession
also data deletion the GDP are also
introduces two new rights one is data
portability and the other is right to
wager and I will talk about this beta
subject rights later and as part of the
enhanced data subject rights the GDP are
also further expands the data the
international data transfer protection
which means that if data flows outside
of the European Union companies have to
make sure that the data has the adequate
level of data protection and the GDP are
also least additional mechanisms
compared to the previous one for example
with our contract clauses now we also
have binding corporate rules and other
certification mechanisms that companies
can use alright so what are the five key
things I wanted to talk about today in
terms of the relation of GDP are and
Google cloud well the first key
difference is that now the GDP are also
applies to cloud providers it means that
it's not only the customer you but us
Google clouds are also responsible for
compliance
I also a second I also wanted to talk
about the suppressor and what does it
mean in terms of you know obligations
for the GDP our Italy workforce are
processors to to process customer data
I'm gonna extend a little bit more about
the extended data subject rights I'm
going to select two rights and I'm going
to demonstrate how we can support the
customers when they the subject have
requested them regarding their data and
fourth I want to talk about the
incredible high fines that the GDP are
introduced
which can be as high as 20 million euros
or 4% of the annual turnover and finally
I wanted to talk about GDP our and
security and I also wanted to showcase
some of the security product features
and configurations that we offer in this
vid that can be helpful with compliance
so number one is data processors as I
mentioned this first point now the GDP
are also applies to cut providers to us
so what does it mean maybe you have
heard the terms data controller and data
processors the GDP are V reintroduces
these terms they were already present in
the European data protection and
directive but now the GDP are further
clarifies and explains their meaning
data controllers are you the customers
were primarily responsible for data
processing what does it mean that you
are the one who determines the purposes
and means of data processing based on
the wording of the law in other words it
means that the customer the the data
controller is the one who decides on the
why and how on the data processing and
we as data processors are the one who
processed it only based on your
instructions and on behalf of the
controller so let me tell you more about
this and how we can how we try to make
our obligations as data processor but
first of all people are very important
so we we are really proud to say that we
have four most diverse foremost experts
in security and they are responsible for
information application and network
security as well they are the one who
maintain or the
system the other security infrastructure
beside on the security review process
also hoppin Bambi with the review
process member aboard vendors
subprocessors and they are also the one
who built Google security infrastructure
and responsible for implementing Google
security policies but we also have a
very extensive team of compliance
professionals and lawyers including
privacy lawyers and our responsibilities
as companions professional is to ensure
that Google as a whole the company are
fully trained and aware about the
leaders data protection standards as an
example we design we design Google's
privacy training program but we also
have policy and compliance experts who
directly engage with the regulator's the
regulators in Europe who are responsible
for imposing those really high fines and
whenever we developing features for
compliance we recheck with them to make
sure that we are going into the right
direction and it can be half of with our
customers compliance needs so it's fair
to say that we are really committed
helping customers in their GDP our
compliance and we're not only saying
this but we put our commitments to
writing as an example we updated our
data processing agreements with new
terms that reflect the changes within
the gdpr and here I wanted to remind you
that in case you haven't done so please
opt in to the most recent a madman's
data processing amendments and I will
show you in a two slides later how you
can do that if you haven't done so by
tuning in to our GDP our GDP our
Resource Center we also state
in our data processing agreement how we
as data processor only process data
based on your instructions also our
employees are required to sign and
confidentiality agreements and they have
to go through mandatory privacy
trainings this is what we the privacy
professional designs and also make sure
that every single person in the company
goes through them our employees also
have to go through code of conduct
training and that training explains the
best practices and expected behavior for
data protection so what do we do
specifically beside the coil beside the
contract when we assist the data
controllers who the customers and GDP
are compliance as I mentioned these
subject rights are incredibly important
under the GD P R and under the GDP are
you have to prepare for a data subject
request to they will ask to access
rectify and restrict their data
processing and we do have built-in
functionality and products where these
requests can be easily mad we also have
a dedicated team who can respond in case
you have any data protection related
inquiry we also we had we had terms
around incident notification for several
years so it's not in use to us and we
continue to promptly notify when we
become aware of an incident and this is
very important under the GD P R because
the GD P R has really strict incident
notification timelines for data
controller for the customer it's 72
hours after you became aware of an
incident
and within this 72 hours you have to
notify the Supervisory authorities us
data processors on the other hand we
have to notify you the controller
without undue delay and again you can
find all these terms in our data
processing amendments and as I mentioned
that I really want to call your
attention to a GDP our resource center
which you can very easily find by
googling GDP our Google and Resource
Center and on the top banner as I'm
showing on the slide you can see where
you can click and opt into the new terms
and please do so to make sure that you
have an agreement which reflects the GDP
our changes on this website you can also
find more details about the things I
described today including some of the
product feature I will describe at the
end so number two use of subprocessors
today's business environment is a little
more complex as having just one data
controller and one data processor and we
Google as well the increases rely on
third-party vendors processing customer
data and it's very important that these
vendors third-party vendors go through
very very rigorous
security and selection process and even
the onboarding process is very it's very
rigorous and for example they have to go
through strict security testing we are
also transparent about this uh processor
via use you can find them on our website
and also there is a link in the data
processing agreement where you can
review the list of them
bethe subject rights as a turning point
again and I decided to use two specific
data subject rights to demonstrate how
being G Street can support in case
customers come to you with data subject
requests
the first one is data return so I
mentioned at the beginning that there
are new data subject rights under the GD
P R and Varro's one of them is data
portability right to data portability
what does it mean data subject did have
the right to access their data even
before the GD P R but the GD P R takes
it even further
it requires that controllers data
controllers has to make this data
available to customers in a
machine-readable structure than commonly
used format they should able to export
it and transmitted to another controller
if they wish without any further
hindrance from the controller now Google
had that a feature even before the gdpr
that made it available both for
customers to retrieve their data export
it and they hid somewhere it's called
the Google takeout and also in G's with
the administrator were able to export
customer data via the functionality of G
Street but for gdpr we took it even
further and we recently before the GDP I
launched and enhanced the attack sport
feature that enables you to download
data for all of your domain and we made
sure that you can do it securely so we
added additional security controls in
there as an example only super admins
who have been with the company for 30
days can do that they have to use
additional
authentication multi-factor
authentication whenever there is
multiple super admins we promptly notify
them if such export was initiated and
also you can only do this if you have
less than 1000 employees otherwise we
have to go through the Google support
team and they can temporarily unable to
feature again to make sure that the data
export happens securely the next one is
data deletion data deletion is not new
writing gdpr but it is still very
important because we want to make sure
that we only store data on unless until
it's necessary for business purpose so
we always had built-in functionality in
G suite and all of its products that
made you made it possible for you to
delete customer data anytime and we also
as we mentioned also in our data
processing amendment and also in a
recent public statement we make sure
that relevant customer data in case we
receive a deletion request from you will
be deleted from our system within 180
days unless of course there are some
retention obligation that apply and this
can be a human
EU member state law requirement or a
litigation hold or tax authorities
sometimes also want us to retain data
longer as an example and now the fine so
probably when I heard first of all the
GD player in the news you read about the
incredible fines
the fines are under the GDP are are
incredibly high no other data protection
legislation could impose such
incredible fines as the gdpr and
whenever you need attention from my
executives at your company I recommend
you to bring up the fines that that
always gets their attention and the fine
of course can be as maximum fine 20
million euros or 4 percent of the annual
turnover the gdpr gives example what are
the scenarios and what are the type of
infringement these these maximum fines
can be imposed and these are related to
the data protection principles I
mentioned at the beginning the subject
rights or the international data
transfer mechanisms and the GDP are also
gives a detailed list of what are the
deciding factors the data protection
authorities that can impose these fines
looking to and things that can be
relevant the type of data that was in
scope fording in infringement these are
sensitive personal data for example it
also depends on your behavior was it was
the infringement the result of a
negligent or intentional behavior did
you have any similar relevant previous
infringement how much did you to do did
you do to mitigate the damage that
resulted from the infringement how how
much did you cooperate with the data
protection authorities so these are
already citing factors and there is more
in the GDP are in article 83 and finally
a fifth point I wanted to talk about the
GDP are and security because EDP is a
data protection law so it has privacy
and security provisions as well such as
other things the GD P R has provision
and describes responsibilities board for
the data controller and the data
processor so you and the customer and us
are both responsible and security is
really at the core of the GDP are the
GDP our doesn't give you an exhaustive
list of product feature that you you
must have in order to be GDP our
compliance and it fairly it would be
files would be very difficult because of
the changing technology but it does
describe that you have to do both both
the control and the process you have to
perform a risk assessment based on the
recent recent state of the art industry
accepted best practices and security and
actually the GD P R does bring up two
examples systemization and encryptions
as some of these best example but really
the point is that you have to be able to
protect your user data from unlawful
access unauthorized access and unlawful
processing so what are some of these
examples we have in in G suite that you
can leverage in GDP our compliance I
want to talk about this feature features
in the context of access monitoring and
access control because these are very
important for your security best
practices so and again I highlighted the
encryption here because the GD P R does
thus highlighting encryption as one of
the example of security best practices
the first one is to stop verification
why do companies need to stop
verification we know that
words can be easily compromised they can
be figured out they can be stolen so
it's very important that especially in
terms of enterprise corporate data which
is more vulnerable in terms of security
vulnerability the two separate
verification gives you an additional
layer when it asked user when they sign
in for additional proof of
identification and one good example is a
security key a physical security key
that you can plug into your laptop
monitor or a desktop so this is
definitely highly recommended we use
this all of all of employees of Google
are required to use it as a security
best practice suspicious login
monitoring so suspicious login
monitoring uses Google's robust machine
learning capabilities to detect
suspicious logins and in order to use
this administrators can sign up for
email alerts and we look at possibly
suspicious behavior examples for example
if someone tries to log into your
corporate account from an unusual
location or from a new unknown device
first the process is in most cases we
send a login challenge to the user and
we typically ask them we send them a
passcode that they have to enter we send
them a passcode in emails or either cell
phone whichever was their selected
method and if the unable to solve this
challenge or avoided then
is Bambi when we send a notification a
very clear notification to the
administrator so that it can take an
action he can take an action mobile
management mobile device management MDM
so we recently launched a feature that
we announced that next terms of MDM
mobile device management as part of our
cloud identity SSO catalog and this is
great because now basic MDM comes by
default on with corporate mobile devices
and that means that employees don't have
to download additional profiles in order
to use this but it comes by default on
boys on Android and iOS devices it helps
the administrator because it gives a
single dashboard dashboard view where
the administrator can see all the
devices that can access corporate data
it can it's very it makes it very easy
to enforce pass codes or remove content
or vibe devices remotely in case they
get from compromised and again the great
thing about is that no no user
intervention needed and this is very
helpful in today's world especially when
corporations have to deal with BYOD
devices for example this solution works
really well and of course as I mentioned
it comes with the basic ambient feature
by the photon but you can always select
more advanced settings
data loss prevention or DRP the AAP uses
optical character recognition or OCR
technologies to scan contents in Gmail
including its attachments files int in
Drive and teen drives and looking for
possibly sensitive content we privacy
professionals are aware which can but
can be potentially sensitive data both
globally and countries specifically as
an example we know that credit card
information and bank account information
is sensitive so we have these by default
turned on and you can very easily turn
these predefined detectors on and off
depending on which countries your
present for example you also define your
own custom rules because you are the one
who know your business you are the one
who know that what sensitive data for
you in terms of intellectual property
and sensitive project codes and you can
define these rules by keywords or using
regular expressions and if you observe
that you receive too many false
positives you can always adjust these
content trash words information rights
management is an axe good example we do
have it available for both for admin
admins within the admin console and
users and what it means is that the
admins can limit file access privileges
for example you may want to restrict
certain sanctifies to make sure that
they can only be shared within the
domain and it gives you a very granular
controls you can define different rules
for teams for example the decision
stairs team as an example are not
allowed to share certain type of files
with an external domain and it also adds
iron controls additional information
rights management controls both for the
admin and and the user and here I'm
showing how it looks from the user
perspective so first of all by default
it's only shared by the user who created
and they have to take additional actions
additional clicks if they want to share
it with others and also again both
administrators and user I can very
easily by checking checkboxes can
disable downloading printing and copying
files and finally I wanted to talk about
enhance the email security Gmail now
offers s/mime and as my person stands
for secure multi-purpose internet mail
extension and this is why we prefer to
call it as mine and really secure is an
important word here so this is now the
industry standard way of encrypting
emails and it cracked and requires
emails to be signed and encrypted when
we send them when it's when they send it
out and it's also important that you can
bring your your own certificates and use
that with as mine but jamia has
additional security features such as TLS
and decay decay or DKIM warnings and i
shown an example here that we try to
give very very clear visual signals in
case we suspect that a user receives an
honor
a message from an uneducated source and
also we we try to be very clear visual
signals if we see that message was
unencrypted so this was the last
security feature I wanted to talk about
today but of course there are more and
you find some of these features both 4G
sweet and DCP at our GDP Resource Center
so please stay tuned for Q&A we were
back in less than a minute
you
hi welcome back we received some
question that I would like to answer the
first question is an interesting one
does the gdpr require data to be stored
in the EU data localization so one great
thing about the GDP are that it does not
require data localization it does
enhances the data transfer mechanism so
it does require that there is an
adequate level of data protection from
data that's flowing outside of the EU
and the GDP are lists
certain mechanism how this can be
achieved or recognized by the DPS and
some of these are the privacy share for
example model model contract clauses
that Google uses and GDP are mentions
other mechanism as well for example
binding corporate rules and you can have
certification as well but this is very
important so as the EU for the European
Union actually its aim to make sure that
the data flows freely within the U so
there are no data localization
requirements the second question is will
all these security features be used only
for EU citizens I I got this I got this
question before it's a very good
question and as someone who worked on
these piracy programs we really do not
differentiate between EU citizens and
other citizens when we have been
preparing for the GDP are so we we make
these features available to everyone
because we believe these are the GDP are
has great data protection practices we
believe that data subject rights are
important we agree with all the data
protection principle so we really want
to make sure that the good things that
came
with gdpr are available for everyone
yeah I have been the third question is
about the GDP our resource center and I
have been talking about the resource
center a lot and so again it's very easy
to find just by googling GDP our Google
and resource center but we will provide
the link in the platform on the Q&A
session someone was asking how can how
can they find out more about deities we
have white paper have synthetic person
and those are those are good examples
again and if I remember correctly you
can actually find it again just go to
the GDK resource center and when we talk
about product features that can be
helpful with the GDP are dialing there
but again you can also just google the
IP or data loss prevention white paper
and I bought the actual IP for another
absent or articles will pop up and same
goes for GCP you can learn about the IP
API for disappear as well
okay so the last question is is there a
continuity between GDP our compliance
and G suite and GCP what are the
counterparts in the larger cloud
offering which features you presented
that I was available in GCP it's a great
question yes there is a continuity
between GDP our compliance with industry
and GCP I am in this with but we worked
very closely with the GCP teams and they
have similar features not exactly the
same who's the product offering is
different but they also have as an
example 2-step verification for DLP data
loss prevention
they have DLP api's they also offer
various products for access monitoring
and control some of them are product
specific for example they have
stackdriver monitoring and logging cloud
security scanners I I believe in app
engine and also security command center
so I actually didn't go through all
these security features because there
are there are many but we have Google
Security Center and Google command
center for G suite and GCP which is very
helpful for the administrators because
it can it can gives them an overall view
of the of the G suite products and
security security positioning what are
so those are those are very helpful and
in case I don't remember all of them
again these product features and more
are available in in the GDP our Resource
Center
so I believe I don't know if we have
more questions but no so we don't have
more questions so again I wanted to tell
you that we do these live webinars every
Tuesday you can check it on the cloud on
our website and we have a next session
coming up and stay tuned towards this is
a CH at observability with open census
and thank you for much thank you so much
for joining in today
you